let's begin by remembering and you can
jot this down for me and help me fill it
in limiting sums these things you have a
look at on Monday yeah give me a nod you
know assure me okay great
limiting Psalms they exist for some
geometric progressions GPS but not
others
what kind of geometric progressions have
limiting sums cuz they don't all what do
you think is acting very good the in
fact the precise technical where we're
looking for is convergent as in they
converge converging is just the verb now
we're looking for what is convergent
mean we're looking for GPS that such as
when you take one partial sum you take
the next one then you take the next one
they are getting closer and closer and
closer to some specific value and of
course we call that specific value the
limiting sum okay now I won't put you on
the spot but I do want to get a show of
hands who has the proof for the formula
of the limiting sum in their book don't
got it I don't ask you to quite up I
just wonder who's actually written it
down any takers just look back a couple
pages one or two hazards in hands that's
fine that's okay I just want to get a
rough indication or do you have a
question is a key I think this is it
okay well I think we need to all get it
so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna take this and it's only like four
or five lines it's not a complicated
formula we're gonna prove it it's not
complicated right so here we gonna go
first we will start with this idea what
is it that makes GP converging it's
something to do with the ratio do you
remember what what is it about the ratio
that makes your GP conversion it takes
on certain values and remember hmm
como between negative one and one
precisely if we have a common ratio from
term to term that essentially is making
the terms successively smaller that's
all we want right by the way why don't
we include the boundaries like why don't
we have less than or equal to why not
why do we have to exclude those
boundaries say if someone else can help
me out here what do you reckon you can
you can just think about it what happens
if R equals one
what kind of series would you get
that first turn was five and I was equal
to one what would the second term be
also five what about the photo also five
does that series 5 5 5 5 does that
converge yes there's no just gonna keep
on getting bigger and bigger forever
we just need to be a bit smaller than
that okay now there is another way that
we can say this negative 1 is less than
R is less than 1 it requires us to
remember our absolute value notation did
you get this in your definition on
Monday so ringing a bell your your
furrowed brow isn't isn't reassuring
reason right someone's getting it the
absolute value of R we want it to be
because absolute values mean you don't
to worry about negatives we actually
want to be smaller still yeah smaller
but this time we're sort of capturing
the negative in 1 here does that make
sense
so it's less than or equal to 1 right so
it's okay we're kind of swimming a
notation at the moment what are we
saying here we've got a common ratio
between each term we want it to be small
is another way to say it right okay so
if this is the case then what we can say
is s the limiting some it exists for
starters right and what it's equal to is
you take that partial sum s of N and
then you just see what happens as n gets
bigger and bigger and bigger now we have
language and notation for this when
something gets bigger and bigger and
bigger what piece or topic of math do we
use when things get thank you parent
bigger and bigger in video starts with
an L
thank you think about it think back to
calculus when we introduced that when
things go toward a certain value yeah
these are limits right so what we're
interested is this ring bells right we
want to think about what happens to that
partial sum as n gets bigger and bigger
and bigger let's just go to the end of
it if you possibly can so here is the
nth partial sum okay so this is our
definition for the limiting sum in fact
it's the reason why we call it the
limiting some it's because it's the
product of a limit or the result of a
limit I should say all right let's think
back what is our formula for the sum of
a geometric series it's that one with
the fraction in do you remember oh the N
on 2 is a fraction that's going to
appear in a different sum which one is
the N on to come in remember well the
JPA what's the other kind that's that's
for a paise yeah arithmetic progression
so for this one I'll give you bit of a
clue it starts with an A hey there's
some brackets right ok so we've got two
versions of this one as you may recall
we could either do R to the N minus 1 or
we could do it in reverse order
can anyone suggest to me why do you
think I'm going to choose this
particular version they both give us the
same answer why do you think this
version might be more suitable have a
look up the top yeah well R is less than
1 right so what we can do here is it
means I can avoid having double
negatives they both like we said will
give us the same answer but I just the
fewer negatives I have to deal with the
better okay fantastic
now here's what's great unlike what we
first learn in calculus as soon as we
write this we can immediately evaluate
the limit we can just say hey look
here's that N it's supposed to go to
infinity right this thing here is some
small number what happens to a small
number when you multiply it over and
over and over again by itself a lot of
times it gets so small in fact it
becomes because we're considering the
limit it becomes nothing right zero okay
so I can write that as I'm evaluating
the limit
one - what does it become again zero all
/ one - ah okay and we're pretty much
there aren't we we just have to say one
takeaway zero is 1 and this should be
the formula that you recognize this is
the limiting sum okay now I'm just going
to briefly hit pause on this and see if
we can also note I think I need to just
quickly turn this back on soup OOP let's
see I'm doing all my technology today
here we go all right now I'm gonna cover
this up and I'll bring it back in a
second what's this this is our formula
our reference sheet okay you can see
it's got the unit you guys are we taking
the HSC that's slightly terrifying
now where's my mouse cursor let me find
where it's gone okay there it is okay so
I'll have a look series of sequences
over here on the right hand side now I
particularly want you to note a couple
of things number one have a look right
down in the bottom at sequence of series
what's that there there it is the
formula we just developed you can see
why let me zoom in a bit for you you can
see why I introduced or reintroduce this
absolute value notation so you recognize
it here but importantly I want you to
know there are no explanations at all
given to you on the reference tree for
what any of these things mean you have
to know what they mean this is just to
aid your memory the understanding is
something we have to get does that make
sense and that's why we went through all
of these efforts but now you know we're
here to find it
it's right there in the front page okay
so we'll come back to this later on can
we quickly go through a very basic
example I'm going to give you guys you
can drop down example one I'm gonna give
you guys a convergent series and I'd
like you to it should only take you
three or four lines max I'd like you to
evaluate its limiting sum here is the
GPE
I'm interested in could you go ahead
like I said won't take you many Lions
you've got the formula right here just
give it a go and raise your hand once
you've got an answer I'd love to have a
quick look okay so did you land is this
where you got to
in fact I have missed off a line what is
the final solution it's a third
fantastic okay now if you've been paying
close attention I want to kind of
illustrate why this is happening a way
that you can gain a sort of geometric
intuition for why this should be the
answer and I'm going to give you at
least three reasons for that okay number
one sometimes you get a question that is
related to the limiting some but in fact
instead of catching it to you in terms
of numbers they'll give you shapes and
then they'll say work out a length or an
area that's formed via a limiting some
sets the first thing the second reason
is you should always seek multiple ways
to think about a single reality that's
kind of the superpower of mathematics
that you can think about things visually
or a thematically or algebraically and
all the rest